[Musique]
c'est mercredi prochain que s'ouvre la
Conférence des Nations Unies sur la
biodiversité la COP15 au Palais des
congrès de Montréal 12 jours de
discussion de conférence dans le but
d'arrivée espérons-le un cadre mondial
pour la restauration de la nature d'ici
2030 avec nous Jean Lemire émissaire au
changement climatique et aux enjeux
nordiques et articles du Québec bonsoir
bonsoir vous êtes biologiste vous êtes
cinéaste navigateur on vous connaît bien
bien sûr quelle est votre rôle dans la
COP15 en fait le Québec nous
représentons l'ensemble des États
fédérés de la planète qui est donc on a
un rôle très important puisqu'on a
décidé que ce prochain cadre mondial
toucherait tous les niveaux de
gouvernement et ça ça a été un gain
important donc maintenant les États
comme la Californie
l'Ecosse ont fait partie vraiment des
négociations et donc c'est un gain
majeur évidemment la plupart du temps la
mise en application de ce qui va être
décidé ce cadre mondial revient aux
provinces puisque c'est un champ de
compétence et donc c'est important
d'être autour de la table évidemment
pour émissaire vous êtes l'autre
exactement de la conférence conférence
qui sera très très importante de quelle
manière quand on parle de la lutte
contre les changements climatiques de
quelle manière la lutte contre les
changements climatiques et la lutte pour
la préservation de la biodiversité sont
des enjeux qui sont très liés c'est très
intéressant parce que on entend beaucoup
parler de carbo neutralité bon la
carbone neutralité ça ne veut pas dire
qu'on va arrêter d'émettre des grs ça
veut simplement dire que on va arriver à
un équilibre à zéro en tout cas on va
émettre et ce que l'on va capter d'ici
2050 le meilleur capteur de CO2 c'est la
nature et donc on a besoin de protéger
cette nature sinon on n'arrivera pas à
atteindre cette carbone neutralité donc
les deux grands défis changement
climatique et biodiversité doivent
travailler vraiment ensemble on doit
enlever ces sil et voir cette nature
comme une solution réelle pour les pour
notre lutte au changement climatique une
solution économique absolument une
solution économique et là il va falloir
faire très attention parce que les puits
de carbone vont prendre de la valeur on
connaît le marché du carbone pour ce que
l'on émet éventuellement il y aura
évidemment des prix pour ce que l'on
capte ce que la nature capte il va
falloir que la science soit au cœur de
cette de cette démarche pour pas tomber
dans l'écho blanchiment non plus donc
c'est vraiment une notion économique on
en est où dans les avancées de
discussion dans notre compréhension qui
pourrait nous permettre justement
d'avoir une entente à la COP15 pour être
franc disons que les négociations
n'avancent pas très vite ça fait déjà 4
ans donc on est sur le texte
en même temps c'est à la COP que se
passe les petits miracles donc on verra
mais on a deux semaines de boulot devant
nous qui font nous demander beaucoup de
travail de corridor et également pour
essayer de convaincre il y a des cibles
que les gens ont commence par les 30% de
protection du territoire au temps
terrestre marin bon évidemment c'est
tout c'est des discussions parce qu'il y
a les fameuses à protégées mais il y a
d'autres mesures de conservation
efficaces donc on est vraiment dans le
dans les définitions on est également
dans un cadre qui demeure très ambitieux
une vingtaine de cible qui touchent
beaucoup de domaines et le monde des
affaires et la finance est vraiment très
impliquée maintenant en biodiversité
donc c'est intéressant jusqu'à quel
point les leaders comprennent ça
comprennent le capital naturel
comprennent la valeur de la des
écosystèmes et de la biodiversité sur le
plan écologique sur le plan du bien
vivre ensemble mais sur le plan
économique en fait ils doivent
absolument le comprendre parce que à peu
près la moitié de l'économie mondiale et
directement relié au service offert par
la nature donc là on parle de 44000
milliards là c'est des chiffres qui sont
impressionnants là donc c'est un peu
notre rôle nous les scientifiques de
vous montrer l'importance de ces
services que la nature nous rend en même
temps il faut le dire on est dans une
relation avec la nature qui ne nous qui
on n'est pas sur une bonne trajectoire
parce qu'on exploite beaucoup plus que
ce que la nature est en mesure de
produire vous savez chaque année il y a
cette fameuse date où on a épuisé ce que
la nature a produit cette année c'est le
24 juillet et plus donc on tombe ensuite
en déficit et cette notion de déficit
pour les gens qui qui nous dirigent
souvent c'est des gens qui sont des gens
d'affaires on le voit bien cette notion
de déficit elle est facile à comprendre
pour les gens d'affaires alors on espère
qu'ils vont la comprendre pour qu'on
puisse avoir un cadre ambitieux ici à
Montréal mais en même temps pour des
gens d'affaires qui sont ensuite des
politiciens qui doivent prendre des
décisions
face à des multinationales qui arrivent
avec des milliards pour investir qui
veulent développer un territoire qui
veulent faire des routes qui veulent
arnacher quelque chose qui veulent
transformer un territoire comment le
leader ne voit pas le gain économique
plus grand de cela que le gain
économique de protéger la biodiversité
c'est le grand défi c'est le grand défi
et c'est notre rôle un peu nous amener
des notions scientifiques qui leur
montrent bien que en ce moment la
trajectoire n'est pas viable à long
terme et donc on doit absolument amener
au terme c'est important ça à long terme
il faut se projeter dans les prochaines
générations absolument parce que c'est
sûr qu'à court terme on peut tout
prendre mais il restera rien pour les
autres alors cette vision à long terme
c'est ce qu'on travaille de plus en plus
dans ces fameuses cops qu'on entend
beaucoup parler que ce soit climat ou
biodiversité essayez d'amener cette
notion de de long terme qu'est-ce qu'on
va laisser pour les générations futures
moi je pense que avec la nature c'est
peut-être un peu plus facile à
comprendre on est tous en amour avec
cette nature là qui nous entoure c'est
peut-être plus facile de protéger ce que
l'on aime alors je pense qu'on peut
faire un bon bout de chemin en
communication en mettant cette
importance sur la biodiversité et la
nature il faut que ça marche les cops il
faut qu'il y ait des vrais résultats
parce qu'après ça il y a des gens il va
y avoir des manifestations des gens qui
s'opposent à la cop27 la COP sur les
changements climatiques la COP15 sur la
biodiversité qui disent ça va pas assez
vite ça n'avance pas et je comprends ça
je comprends ça mais on est pris dans un
système de décision onusien qui passe
par l'unanimité des pays et donc
évidemment c'est ça qui est très très
lourd et c'est pour ça que c'est long ça
prend beaucoup de négociations de
corridor et tout ça mais
proposez-moi un autre système et je vais
je vais être heureux de l'analyser en
même temps regardons ce que nous avons
fait comme progrès en climat quand on a
commencé l'école on s'en allait plus
vers cat à 6 degrés d'augmentation en ce
moment on s'en va plus vers 2.5 2.8 il y
a eu c'est encore beaucoup trop mais il
y a eu quand même une amélioration mais
c'est l'urgence d'A qui doit nous nous
motiver à réussir cette copie c'est la
COP la plus importante en biodiversité
ça doit être un moment à Montréal à un
moment historique bonne chance merci
merci beaucoup Jean-Louis pour voir nos
émissions en entier rendez-vous sur la
chaîne ici RDI